[Music]
[Applause]
hi guys it is at the 37 I think it's
America how's it going I know you can't
answer but if you answer good that's
good to hear
I'm turning that down sorry that went
the wrong way I'm Nick Youssef welcome
to the show I um I'm happy about this
episode
it's a my good friend Bobby Lee it's
trying to get him on earlier but Bobby
is it busy dude Bobby's hosting his own
very awesome and successful podcast
called tiger belly you should check it
out it's doing real real well not in the
ratings and stuff and it's just you know
Bobby being Bobby at his best so check
that out after you check this out and I
think I'm going to be on it at some
point soon about out Bobby's on my
podcast this week talking about a bunch
of just insane stuff but real quick a
couple of road things June 11th through
19th in New York City I'll be all over
town doing a bunch of spots as the stand
stand-up New York New York Comedy Club
and a couple other shows I'll post all
that stuff on Nikki so calm so be sure
to check that out
July in San Francisco July 6 through 8
I'll be headlining the San Francisco
punchline one of my favorite clubs ever
so get tickets to that if he does are up
now you can go to the punchlines website
google Nikki's F punchline in San
Francisco and I think there also might
be a link on on my website to up again
Nick Youssef calm and then I Tempe
improv July 22nd to 24th and more stuff
to come and I'll announce it when it is
ready to go so keep this intro short and
sweet oh yeah real quick to the giveaway
stuff that I did a few episodes ago I
know I haven't sent that out yet and one
of you has reached out and said hey is
that's still coming
of course it is coming I apologize for
the delay but your prizes are still on
their way I've just been out of town and
just you know other stuff so sorry about
that
those are coming and I think that's it
so yeah this episode with Bobby we
talked about where he you know came from
where he grew up what his childhood was
like what what makes Bobby Bobby hell he
had a pretty wild childhood man and I
asked him about a lot of like Korean
stereotypes that I've always thought
were you know prevalent and a lot of
families and he says it's somewhat true
definitely wasn't true you know with his
family and and in him and his brother
and stuff but yeah it's a really
interesting episode he tells a bunch of
pretty wild stories so it makes for a
very interesting and very funny episode
we left a good amount of the time and I
hope you do too so I subscribe to this
podcast if you have stumbled into it and
haven't done that already if you use
iTunes the reviews and stuff and the
ratings really help and every every week
I've seen a couple of new ones and that
makes me feel very happy that you guys
are listening and hearing me when I'm
like please rate and review and you're
doing it so let's get a few more up this
week if you haven't done it and right
now you're at a computer or you're you
know looking at your phone you're not
busy doing you know multitasking get on
iTunes rate review and you know tell a
friend tweet about it Instagram Facebook
something you know let someone know try
to build this thing into something
something bigger so thank you in advance
and thank you again if you have already
done that so that being said enjoy this
episode with Bobby Lee see you next week
alright let's try that again how happy
are you to do this podcast
that joke is over that's not no one
heard it the first time
oh do it again then yeah this is like
live how happy are you to do this
podcast I am at from what 1 to 10
yeah I'm in pain D [ __ ] you that's how
happy I am I'm past the 10 to 90 yeah
this didn't have to be an aside I could
have been oh this is just this right
here dude you know is this right here is
how much I [ __ ] love you that that
you're in my [ __ ] house on a Saturday
just shut the [ __ ] up all right
and I'm like you're on a Saturday I
don't want to but that's how much I like
you so you should be having like a
hard-on right now hold on first of all I
do have a hard-on second yeah I try to
do this on many weak because I [ __ ]
said you movie that you would at the
Comedy Store and then you're like is too
many people move but that's the most
convenient also at night and better this
is my mind is a wig p.m. I woke up at
5:00 this is breakfast I'm stupid what
about when you do morning radio well you
knew when you do morning radio you
[ __ ] [ __ ] and that's all so let me
just say something you're like the way
you're dressed right now you're like TV
ready
she was [ __ ] a podcaster oh this is
just Howard your hair you all looking
fancy new vans jacket I always I always
do my hair that's just my hair yeah this
is coming from a guy who wears a poncho
that's fine you walk around in EM poncho
I was born in a poncho no time you know
but I was born a little off kilter I
know that and so ever since I was a kid
I got I get to dress however I wanted
okay that's why you're the perfect guest
for this night why what's it called what
you theme the theme is me and my fellow
ethnic and/or immigrant friends
comedians or otherwise yeah talk about
our our upbringings in our lives
ooh fancy and see what the differences
in similarities are um yeah and you are
well let's take the Korean stereotype
because I encountered this a lot with
you
when people like encounter you and go
what the [ __ ] is going on with you
you're on like any other Korean we've
ever met mm-hmm how do you well I'm well
in the beginning when I was a kid
it felt I felt lost because I did I mean
I was born in San Diego but we lived in
Minnesota for about 10 years yeah and
how did that my parents owned a clothing
business called fashion gang this was
this their film yeah but they don't own
it anymore but um so they had stores out
there and I this is during the 70s
yeah and I just remember horrific just
social situations really at school and
whatnot really Korean [ __ ] there was
another guy named Tom Roach but he was
adopted okay he doesn't count I don't
say adopted I say abandoned he was
abandoned he was abandoned by his Korean
purpose and they'll take it I want why
why people whoa yeah but why doesn't he
count if he's a Korean because their
experience are a little different a lot
of them believe they're white when
you're when you're an Asian guy or a any
ethnicity and you're in a white
environment all your life yeah I
personally don't end there because later
in life I guess they try to search for
ya I was in Texas once and this Korean
dude walked up to me after a show
because hey could I talk to you I go
yeah he goes yeah I was abducted and um
I don't know any of you like I don't
know any Asians can I just hang out with
you what I go no why no why I don't know
well we have taken total strangers to
dinner after chef I understand that but
he had a chill song we vibe that's
what's who's that the guy that shot up
Virginia Tech oh I just have a choice um
we radar IQ especially with Koreans and
I can read it I got another guys in a
snap Wow yeah so yeah I didn't hang out
with him but you know you did run the
risk of him snapping when you said no
you know I was in a public I was in a
public situation
so was the Virginia Tech guy yeah it was
a surprise attack okay Virginia
I'm studying I'm in a class right yeah
it's the last thing right but since I'm
aware of it every movement I'm aware
okay
hey so Luke will check this out hey sue
okay so I was grew up in a white family
can I hang out with you know as soon as
he moves I'm gone
you just run yeah because I know but he
didn't some fine okay yeah yeah so you
have like a radar for those types of
Koreans or Asians yeah
Koreans especially Creon's are crazy
we're a uh I think the 50 years of
oppression by Japan hardened us in a
weird way yeah
is that worthy like super strict not
ringing no I mean I check this out if
you look at just a shin comedians in
general yeah it's usually Koreans yeah
we talked about this before they never
noticed that but it's like almost all
the Asian not all of them but a lot of
them are yeah Steve Byrne Kevin Shay
Margaret Cho me what's dr. Ken he's
going to Randall Park did stand up for a
little bit Randall Randall yeah there
are some that aren't the Filipinos but
the Filipinos are the same way for some
reason yeah they were also oppressed by
different groups of you know mean people
yeah and I believe that dad has
something to do with comedy I don't know
what the connection is okay but I
believe that and also we're a very like
emotional very physically violent
because I was really even even like even
like I mean South Korea is not known to
exhibit any of those like yeah but if
you look at look if you look at the UFC
then yeah the Asian fighters are on the
UFC like a Korean Zombie there's another
guy that just fought that's very good he
fought Cub Swanson the Korean alright
and you know and the best fighters are
Filipinos too right Manny Pacquiao I
think there's a correlation I don't know
what it is though I don't think it's I
don't think it's coincidence yeah so
we're better I'm not saying we're better
I'm just saying is that yeah that is
there so what so your parents were like
that your mom and dad grew up like like
hardened I my mom when she was a kid
she was a kid during the Korean War and
she was walking her aunt and her sister
to school her little sister my aunt yeah
and so it took like two miles say they
got really early and it was during the
Korean War and my mom they went lame
even I don't know a half a mile or
whatever and she thought up fer got a
book so she goes I'm gonna run back up
to the house you stay here and then when
she went back to her sister was a
military truck had went around the
cocoon and ran her over and half her
body was on one side of the street and
the other half was on the other I mean
it was literally like Hornet okay
so then my mom had to go back up to tell
her parents right and so my uncle came
down with during the war there's no
ambulance yeah so he had rice these
empty rice bags and he had to pick up
the carcass and then you know into the
bags and then they brought went up and
buried like my aunt that's my mom's one
of her earliest memories Jesus yeah so
you could imagine you know she comes to
America meets my dad and my dad also
kind of an alcoholic and that kind of he
is and a violent guy and goes together
wow what a party yeah party parties
every night man what a party mmm so it
did they met here yeah and my dad's
talked to my mom really yeah he didn't
want any with them and um she moved
actually to Wisconsin that's from Korea
- no she went stay met in LA okay
she met my dad and he freaked her out so
much like he had just like being like a
drunk being aggressive anyway I love you
guy that kind of thing and so she went
to Wisconsin and guess what happened he
went to call her
why he showed up with meat wait like a
steak or something that's what she said
really take a prime cut like okay when
you're cooked or I'm gonna cook it for
you I don't know Robbie like yeah I
brought dinner no it was raw meat okay
yeah that's weird
no but that's a Korean thing really neat
that's good we hold on it's a Korean
thing to show up with the raw meat much
better meat or roses
um what is it rose dies yeah after about
five days meats already dead and then
you're gonna eat it
it's sustenance yeah where you can look
at for a week [ __ ] roses I mean I guess
showing up with food
yeah is well I don't you do I mean yeah
I don't know I'm just telling you a
story bro right now I know I mean my
parents aren't here to defend it you
know I mean Bobby's but when it's a
weird story people are gonna have a
question yeah [ __ ] it was that would be
her she basically went ah alright that
is a good kind of stick also exact if
there's no like back in the late 60s how
many other Korean dudes are out there
and so she was just like he's his heart
is there yeah and when they not open to
dating white people were they like in
America going I got to find another
Korean quick they're not those types
they're not the date outside another
Steve Byrnes mom type yeah yeah so uh so
they got here in the sit down what
happened was they got married yeah and
then she realized that he was an
alcoholic
yeah and then the beating started I mean
sheshe her teeth are not real
what the first front ones cuz he'd
knocked him out she's I remember which
is where after when you were I was a kid
a kid yeah like three in the morning
like my brother and I Steve and I used
to sleep in the same room uh-huh and uh
listen to my mom's in the room and then
she's like crying and then she opens her
mouth and her like the Chiefs mouth is
like her teeth are red
the [ __ ] how old are you I was seven
and then six okay and then us
barricading the door that he was coming
through yeah and um yeah that's that was
my life your whole childhood was that
kind of stuff well my parents are
midgets
so um didn't take long before I mean my
dad is literally under five foot both of
them oh my god I know and when kalila
met them she's like holy [ __ ] they're
midgets
she's like I could beat up the road yeah
so when I was 14
I'll groom yeah 15 and then what did
they hit you - OH
but because she [ __ ] out of me until you
were formed yeah because I was always
but here's the thing though my brother
and I were always like just causing
trouble anyway I don't think it had to
do with our upbringing maybe genetics
you don't think yeah because even when I
was like 2 I was rushed to the hospital
because I opened up a tiny long bottle
and I ate them all okay right which is
like a precursor to I think my drug
addiction I mean I'll tell you why
because I know that you know I knew that
if I had a headache or somebody had a
headache they would take it you think I
feel better I don't know maybe there's a
connection but even as a kid I was in
trouble might like my grandmother yeah
we went to Korea and she's paralyzed
from the neck down
wait really my grandmother was okay I'm
a stroke yeah so she never left the room
there she stayed in a room she was she
lived for 20 years 25 years after the
show paralyzed from the neck down she
lived with you and your mom no no we
would go visit Korea okay then one day
my dad noticed a welt all over her body
okay oh my god I better go yeah yeah
yeah and and I was probably ten eight
eight years old whatever yeah and then
my dad says the next day he walks comes
back into the room or his mom was and my
brother just super sick no you're not
my grandmother guard you good
because you think she was smiling she
couldn't feel it she was hanging out
with her grandkids yeah but we were
beating this yeah that ever was fixed
but that's what I'm saying is that I
just remember being like that that is
insane
yeah I mean okay but do you think that
that's a genetic thing or like like
you're born that way but also it's like
you've seen that behavior from your dad
I'm Ellen that way that does it so now
do not adem did my parents together just
they created to [ __ ] Eve looking I
evil kids just like crazies what so from
as young as you can remember you I was
always in trouble I was always like when
in Minnesota
I found a Playboy magazine and I cut out
all the vagina parts and I pasted it
around campus like stuff I got oh my god
I got rubble for that you know
and what did your parents do they beat
me they just like punished you and then
you just kept going you like candy got a
point where they just thought soon when
the drugs started happening when I was
like 13
yeah smoking pot and stuff yeah I mean I
went to three rehabs by the time I was
17 and you were when did you move back
from Minnesota 11 in Diego 11 okay so
the drugs and all that stuff started in
this any-any what what going from
Minnesota to San Diego was a real I
that's where my life started I believe
because when you when you live in
Minnesota and you don't see people that
look like you except a chart or there
were some Koreans there yeah there was
some Koreans there but I just
in school especially I didn't see any
yeah
and so that though when when you were in
school were you always like what you
picked on told you were different
no I was just uh I think they were
afraid of me because you're probably
like so I was just like no it was I
feared them you knew there must have
just been fascinated by yeah just was a
weird guy kid that like OCD yeah that's
the vagina guy is actually helping us
out
oh but then imagine going to where I
grew up in San Diego and you show up
this is well sixth grade yeah and you
see Filipino kids with mustaches like
fold with machetes
you know like other kids that look like
it Mexicans
yeah a few blacks you know and you go oh
like this day is where it is yeah
and you use skaters remember you know
I'm in San Diego 380s your identity kind
of started coming yeah man and and then
my cousin Paul lived here and that's
when the drugs and all that I mean I
remember the reason why I like the
Velvet Underground and Roxy Music all
these weird bands even bad then was
because a Kurosawa zone my cousin Paul
talking all that [ __ ] cuz yeah your
parents weren't into rock and roll that
sort of my cousin pulled out my cousin
Paul I would probably be somewhere else
right oh yeah
maybe dad so he taught you could be cool
and like listen to he Americanized you
yeah I was really into like film and
yeah you know he was very artsy fartsy
back then right how much older was in
three years and um yeah and then I desk
just went into my drug ears you know is
that cuz it him too is like you know but
now I gotta talk before the but you know
I mean I had done acid with him and yeah
and um there was some fun [ __ ] times
man I remember like is he he's three
years old or at my sophomore in high
school he his parents kind of an
apartment like by my house yeah cuz they
moved to Oregon and I remember in his
apartment
we were on acid and we're watching the
movie platoon is 13 years old
yeah and no no I was now a sophomore huh
it was just like I just a great what a
great movie on your honor well you're
young and you're on acid
it's so [ __ ] disturbing but yeah I
mean he taught me a lot you know but
back to Asians yeah Asian is it he is
Korean yeah uh where's he now
I think he's in Oregon you know talk to
him anymore some things happen uh uh
some things out but you can't talk about
I can okay what happened well um I made
a mistake yeah on a podcast I said that
which I'm doing it now which is [ __ ]
in your face let's say [ __ ] anything
I want to make the same mistake again
okay but I said that his younger brother
Andy who was very close to yeah I said
on a couple podcast we sucked each other
off I know it's a couple bugs is the
third time he's making this you know I'm
not saying it's true it's not true it is
when we were kids right I mean we were
what yeah we were kids no my girl kids
are blowing by apparently but then like
it got weird and and then Andy's mom
found out yeah right who's my mom's
sister right and she called me I was
living with Sarah um I was dating Sarah
oh okay and you're living here years ago
and I remember calling me one morning
screaming at me keep it up you're gonna
suck it up they like screaming yeah
about that
hi we didn't suck each other you know
whatever you say whatever you're saying
and then um two months later
but then my she yelled at my mom and
then talked for years why was your one
said well uh she I told her everything
yeah I mean she knows every little thing
like whenever like when I graduate from
high school I used to go to Adelita
what's that it's a brothel in Tijuana
and I used to you know go to my mom hey
mom can I get a hundred bucks
why well cuz I do the chores and errands
of stuff she does oh yeah okay but what
you gonna do with that I'm gonna go to
Adelita and I will go to Adelina and I
would tell her about it what would she
do
because I was sober
I was in a a yeah and that I was dad
changed in their eyes they were fine
with that yeah so lucky
he also knows unfuckable I was pretty
much done talkable oh my god so your
parents from the like get-go or just
like yeah these are in money because
Margaret's parents like she's had such a
great communication with them in that
way yeah I think that's very and as a
good ethnic thing you know normally it's
not like that there's no like
communication emotional anything with
like a lot of ethnic I mean look at
David Cho same thing David Chu and his
mom open book open book
Wow yeah my I met my parents and I have
an open book is that common now in
Korean I don't know but the Korean is
that I know it's open really because I
fly whenever at a Korean restaurant and
we just saw a kid who's like college and
his older Korean parents screaming each
other at a restaurant about his life in
Korean yeah right and they're just loud
and they they don't care if it's out
there Wow it's that you know the
stereotype that Asians are submissive
and quiet yeah generally not true no
Japanese Korea Chinese yeah or a lot
like that but some of them are some of
the races interested so Koreans are more
like you know I believe that I could be
wrong
yeah this is my experience I guess I
mean you had this you David Margaret I
mean you guys all got into the arts and
entertainment so that was just kind of
in you guys anyway yeah but what made us
do it you know and right it's it's I
don't know I mean there is something
there and it's also my relationship with
those two it's it's like you know how
like when I started doing stand-up I was
like immersed into the Mexican stand-up
world you know I used to open from
Mencia Carlos and then I used to arm I'd
you know K loco and yeah the Latino
laughs first of all all these it's like
a coincidence or you know it would be
only it was the only that it's the only
group of comics that accepted me yeah at
that time so like the white girl in the
mainstream clubs right back then like a
Largo and all these alt rooms are big
yeah
they didn't want me you know so I just
would do gigs in West Covina or whatever
you know or and so um what was I even
talking about about oh yeah so but
Mexicans they used to fight like that
comics like Jeff Garcia wants to kill
Johnny Sanchez these guys want to like
each other you know Carlos Mateus
strangled George Lopez at the Laugh
Factory don't remember that it's the
other way around
Lopez strangled I mean yeah Lopez got
strangled Carlos Mencia had but with
Koreans there is none of that they all
just get along it's not that we get
along it's just I don't see it ever
happening right it's a lovefest even
like Ali Wong she's getting big she's
creative it shows that she is where is
she I don't know I need something you
know she's a mix of two things I think
she is half Korean maybe yeah anyway
yeah um even you know I mean her success
I know that mom is happy with her I'm
happy with her and it's it's cool I want
to see other Asians make it until
there's too many and then you're like no
I want you out of my way your typical I
think I'm past that now yeah well I mean
you are well because nobody only because
of the fact that I'm old yeah like I've
been around for so long that it's just
there's nothing I can do so you're like
I can't change my age I can't change the
time all the things that have happened
happened and there's I mean I'm just
accepting what's coming along now so
it's different in like Korean culture I
suppose as like compared to like let's
say like Middle Eastern culture like
Indian or something like that like the
kids are supposed to be like a certain
way the sandwich like you have to you
know be a lawyer go to med school look
good for for the family the community
we're like that too we're more like that
than most I think but at the same time
it's more of like open and exciting ones
that you get away here's my point okay
is is that I have 28 first cousins Jesus
yes
he all went to college yeah they all had
jobs
my brother and I already old my brother
even graduated from ASU I'm the only one
wondering what was his degree in like
Hotel Management gonna be like that oh
but I am also deck end
I'm not kidding yet he was there circle
yeah right yeah you can get it together
oh yeah I'm the only one so I think that
it is there but the ones that get away
they get away and they go the opposite
direction I think yeah it's like an
everywhere I think alright yeah but
that's yeah I guess that's a stereotype
you here with like ethnic families where
it's like the parents are super strict
and you have to do XY and z that's why
we came to this country bla bla bla bla
but you know you and your brother the
only two out of everybody in your family
that no but I mean to Paul and Annie
we're crazy okay my cousin Eddie is a
skater Ilan skate shot I mean I have
their there yeah but I was the black
sheet for four yeah and but I had for
some reason I'm always able to get it
together like I you know I was 15 years
survived but then I had 12 years body so
when I do I'll do my binges I can get it
real fast yeah did the UM the
Enlightenment or the awakening of oh
[ __ ] this isn't going well you know so
what did your parents do when you were
like a teenager when you were like being
crazy with the like they just spent
money could we have insurance so they
would just spend money on rehabs well I
tell you it's all just work they
probably spent about $100,000 on rehabs
Wow and um yeah I can't imagine what
they went through I mean it I just feel
bad about it you know I do if I think
about it I went through with me yeah
every day must have been like another
thing what the [ __ ] I'm just mad it's
just I was violent yeah I was
like I ran away from home for like a
month
me and my cousin Andy Twitter Robert
Ross Dress for Less really yeah and he
got arrested and I got away I was a
getaway driver oh my god
yeah and I drove up to LA yeah there you
go and I slept out of my car and how far
you got away you're like I'm leaving the
whole region of San Diego yeah and then
I came home to get clothes and um I
didn't know my mom was home her car
wasn't in the parking lot huh or the
garage or driveway and I am I just not
getting she was there on my bed sleeping
crying how long had you been gone at
that point I don't know a couple weeks
okay Jesus and I beat the [ __ ] out of
her because she was in your bed she was
crying I don't know she was it bothered
me so um I like I theater I bet I beat
her silly
you're joking I'm not kidding I feel bad
about it well I mean I hope but I got
that was the that was the savant that's
where that's over though that was my
bottom yeah I think I think a lot of
people's bottom and then you're like all
right mom says we have now but I mean
they're not all I mean when I was in
rehab I um there's a thing called knees
to knees okay where you know the people
are in the rehab and their family comes
and you're in a [ __ ] cleared
conference hall yeah and everyone forms
a circle okay and you take two chairs
you put in the middle of the circle and
you sit knees to knees with a family
member and you say dark things or things
that they're trying to you know a lot of
other people in front of other people we
shift so I said to my dad we're doing
these two [ __ ] together and I go dad
when I was when when we lived in the
know so no I was molested by a guy with
Down syndrome for like a whole summer
and you could hear a pin drop in the
room and then my does all my dad dead
yeah he started laughing no way yeah and
then my brother started laughing then my
mom started laughing and then I started
laughing
so we now look like the craziest people
in the world everyone else yeah we do
that she because his lab made me love
like why would the [ __ ] would you laugh
at that but then it's like then I'm like
oh yeah it's weird
you know man yeah yeah yeah we all laugh
you know that's that's us Wow
yeah so what is the kit like is there a
Korean community in San Diego and how
did they handle your parents would you
guys like I don't even think they knew I
existed really because you know they
were so shameful of me I they don't
never really was never brought up okay
but they went to like accuse another
event that I remember that when I was we
should have these family gatherings
everyone lived in San Diego at the time
yeah and my dad's sister they're all
drinking and there's probably about
30-40 people you know and she says she's
drunk she says to my dad I don't know
why you marry my me on my mom she is
ugly
she said that out loud so he's right so
that my dad I could see him look at her
and the next thing you know he grabs a
butter knife from the table he lunges
across the table right to kill her right
it was a uh oh my god how many people
were there like twenty thirty Jesus you
think I just remember food flying you're
mean and you know me and my brother
running away laughing insane that's [ __ ]
yeah I mean that's literally what I grew
up with insanity there's a whole
families that way you know what I'm
crazy that just you know we were livers
it's a liver we like to live that's just
wild yeah I mean I know it's crazy but
you're I mean there's a lot of families
that are like that yeah you know we're
the holidays are insane everyone's
fighting and yeah drunk but that's why I
mean he's an alcoholic so yeah you know
was that all he did or did you other
drugs they don't even know what drugs
are really just booth
yeah yeah like I've never even seen
marijuana thank God because if you look
okay I don't know
oh yeah yeah he's making lampshades out
of our skin whatever the kid why do you
like tonight oh yeah dude but what's
cool is is that you know and then when I
started doing stand-up
they just weren't they were just so
disappointed that was the distance all
the rehabs all that because I had been
sober for like six years when I started
doing stand-up so they were like always
on the right track yeah but I got the
mono 17 okay and I started doing
stand-up when I was 23
okay so I had all kinds of jobs from 17
to 23 I worked on the construction
waited tables with the coffee shops
uh-huh
but then I was like maybe I'll go back
to junior college to get my degree or
whatever so they're like okay this you
know he's sober he's ruined and boom the
bombshell I think I want to be a
stand-up comedian and your dad picked up
a butter knife yes yeah I mean that's
what I felt like yeah and then and then
and refused to get it like I I watched
the Comedy Store but then like you know
you didn't pay much well so when I moved
to LA I lived in Silver Lake do you
remember that I gotta know you then no
yeah I need them I'm helped you move out
of that house and remember you you were
like in Silver Lake yeah yeah on the one
to the street right that one and yes
yeah yeah Wow you knew me then did we
met in we met like 16 years ago oh my
gosh is to host the open mic at the
store yes yeah you had me and you were
like are you really a teenager you're a
baby just like yeah yeah and you were
like I'm gonna put you up on the open
mic every time I host and then I would
give you rides home yeah I have a car
the identical car yeah so I'd give you a
ride to that place and then we were like
we started becoming friends and stuff
you had like help me out with however
you could if you if I needed like money
or ever clean my car
right humble give me five boy yeah and
then when you were moving out of that
place you were like hey I got to get rid
of all this [ __ ] and you just had
clothing and shoes everywhere
it was just [ __ ] yeah awesome [ __ ]
and I didn't have like cool clothes yet
I just had the stuff literally out some
of it I was wearing from high school
yeah I know really you're like a six
foot five I don't know if I buy for
right yeah yeah the jeans were like this
no no way there's no way some of the
jacket maybe yeah and then a bunch of
the shirt shows are all my first really
cool graphic t-shirts yeah who are like
cool shirt we're literally I would be
like Bobby Lee oh that's so fun the
first thing they'd be like there's no
how does that fit I don't know hey it
just would yeah but and then I took all
the rest of that stuff I remember you
going like you're like I don't want to
deal with it
I'm just going to throw it away I'm like
dude you know how much you can get if
you resell this it like wasteland or
crossroads and yeah I can make money
doing this I was like yeah okay well you
take it all there and sell it and then
we'll like split the profits and then I
took it I was like well this is going to
take like a few ground I gotta go this
place was one borough yeah and then you
didn't even all you had to do was wait
for me to do that you're like let's do
complicated keep all the money yeah and
then I just kept it all I made like 300
bucks that's amazing maybe more that's
amazing just selling all your awesome
old clothes yeah some of it you'd never
even worn I'm a good dude you're in that
way yeah but see that was but in that
building that was the second place okay
all right I lived upstairs from there
with 11 dudes
wait what called the dumpster so the
thing that you moved me out of was a
renovated one that when I got mad tv I
moved out of the dumpster okay which was
upstairs where my brother and Callisto
and all these guys lives Wow right yeah
so when I was living in the dumpster
they should call it the dumpster it was
a dump to canalize urine how bit little
one-bedroom bedroom 11 people it was
like a [ __ ] commune we let anyone say
there I don't have skaters we man stayed
there a bunch of people say yeah whoa
and everyone's rent was like 8 bucks
yeah oh no no no and then we had a
runaway
seventeen-year-old girl from Beverly
Hills who's a meth addict whoa and she
cleaned the place we are amazing to take
a toothbrush and some sub are so and
later knighthood but before the two
three yeah so a lot of math yeah yeah
we're cleaning yeah but that Dan dude I
used to call my mom every month yeah for
money okay and it was painful to ask for
money
oh my god every month yeah I usually all
ask for money sometimes I feel and now
because the work I also at that time I
was 28 haha 28 29 years old okay I'll
call you every month for like two three
hundred dollars okay and um and they
used to give me the hardest [ __ ] time
of course but check this out I've for
the last 12 years I've sent my parents
four grand a month
Wow and it was sometimes I remind them I
could remember how hard it was to get
$300 yeah I mean you four grand
I know my own heart for no easy this is
yeah you know what it is a ha ha ha you
know they did they laugh it off but you
know well but yeah I mean it was it was
a struggle up here but things it wasn't
you know you made it kind of quick after
moving up here I don't think I did you
don't think so you're up here like two
three years I got on MADtv and then
we're on that Ford yeah but those three
years old were the darkest years well I
mean oh I'm sure you were [ __ ] here
are you right I was very left a lot of
people have seven or eight of those dark
years and then there's like Oh anything
ever thirty or thirty and thirty people
have been doing it first and they still
have them it's so sad to like the people
that you still see at the Comedy Store
oh my god I can't I don't want to name
names but I want to 25 years later and
they're just like Lama and
Oh sign up this week and maybe it'll
happen it was so funny last night um
dice went up yeah and he went up before
me uh-huh
and he went a little long where did you
like a half hour a little longer huh and
I'm sitting back there with Kevin Nealon
and a couple of guys and they were kind
of I don't know how they were feeling
I'm a little you know but I was loving
it because it reminded me back from when
the store when we first when I first
worked there yeah how dice and men see
and these guys are and if I complain
Eddie Griffin yeah and it it just gave
me a little taste of what it was like
yeah that felt good yeah cuz now you're
like in at the primetime hour if it
doesn't matter it just it just how you
know you have to get walk away from
yourself right sometimes yeah
and you have to step back and look at it
for what it is and because we get caught
up in like where's my show where well
how about me but if you take a step back
and look at what you're doing and you
know it's it's pretty fun yeah writing
yeah I mean if you compare now to like
when you were living with eleven
roommates and even then it's like
exciting yeah it's exciting and in
retrospect oh for sure you have all
these stories and it was just like ya
know what what would happen tomorrow
yeah I mean it the idea where there is
it there is a feeling where it's like I
don't know how one makes it yeah because
you see it what sucks about LA is that
you see it around you yeah you know
people I just booked a [ __ ] show yeah
and you're like working the door right
and you have no money and you're like
how does that happen
who do you and they're like yeah my
agents and manager how do you get I know
no one tells you they're like yeah I
went to lunch with my casting director
friend how did you meet that I know I
don't even know who that is
everything's a mystery everything's a
mystery yeah exactly yeah minute
improv now how who books how do you do
it yeah never know you drive down the
street you see your friend on a
billboard yeah there you go
I don't even yeah how does that even and
that process is started a year and a
half before the Billboard like that and
you just have zero idea yeah but now I
know are you yeah they go hey here's all
this money show up on yeah I mean this
last show which one the ABC show my show
got picked up
Oh real yeah congratulations thank you I
didn't know that it's a midseason it's
fine God now you're complaining but it's
13 I'll call again splitting up together
okay with Jenna Fischer and Oliver
Hudson yeah when you play I play on the
front I'm always a friend
is it an Asian centered character you're
just a guy well I mean I'm married to an
Asian woman okay but you're not we're
all no we don't speak it okay no exit no
I'm just a regular dude okay how did
that feel probably good but it wasn't I
rarely do I mean animal practice to have
an Asian accent you [ __ ] ace know what
there you go okay but you've played
other things yeah but I only do it if
it's like I did it
dictator yeah because it's social I'll
do it if they asked right if he asked
yeah that's the right thing and it's the
right thing but I'm not going to do it I
remember Jamie Kennedy offering me
something three years ago do this movie
and I'm like I read it I'm like no that
I won't do that yeah way love you're not
that good you know I mean I'll do it if
if it's like if it's like you're in a
scene with Tom Hardy and it's
Christopher Nolan directing yeah I'll
work advice party-ready have your I
don't give a [ __ ] I'll wear the yellow
makeup everything and the tape will be
visible I'll buy might be talking about
you
but yeah this thing was a miracle how
this happened how did it happen I just
was driving down the street and my agent
called me and goes you just got a show I
got what I told you I could I thought he
he said I had to go read alright I go I
told you I told you that I didn't want
to read this year yeah no they gave you
one without any without anything okay I
go oh that's been your dream it's my
dream since MADtv yeah when did did a
table greet you shot it and it got
picked up yeah that's awesome yeah how
many episodes 13 suite and Ellen
DeGeneres is producing it and who and
you see you Jenna Fischer you sent by
the office is off yeah and then you know
Oliver Hudson
I don't think setting Kate Hudson's
brother okay cool and um I don't you
know Bernie you don't know what will
happen so now you're going to be on that
you're on love what else um why are you
being sarcastic no because I'm doing
giraffe skits oh you're asking me well
you're doing really well these last few
years I remember a few years before that
like you know title yeah we were on the
road together oh my god suicide you were
doing a lot of road work cuz you weren't
working a lot here you had done you know
a movie here movie there a you know bit
part it was it was a darkest when those
times yeah we're the darkest and a
member and I wish I didn't stress out
and cry so much
yeah because I had a lot of moments of
like especially when when Randall and
Ken came out of the scene and Ken Jong
and rental parks and they were booked
everything which is their talented guy
that I love those guys a lot and had no
hard feelings I mean I love them yeah
and I'm happy but they had a monopoly in
the town yeah and I felt like oh no one
loves me anymore eat yummy and so and
you're in like a lava core you're on the
road and some gigs on grey
and it's depressing and it makes you
feel even further away yeah you feel far
away from you know and you're like you
know what but then it's like you just
kind of go you know what you have to
accept it and you have you can't be
bitter about it you have to go I had my
time yeah or this is just that this is
just a phase this is like a I could this
just somebody last night when you when I
saw dice yeah he's a great example of
this yeah here's a great example because
or even Louie Anderson you just have to
walk through your fear stay in the game
you don't quit yeah and it'll always
come back around I feel a little bit of
that happening right now you know I also
um I mean I don't want to I don't want
to sound like an [ __ ] but I'm also
extremely flexible and open now when I'm
on set and doing jobs what do you mean
there was a time where I was I'm not
doing that
really oh yeah so why would you sound
like in that okay like like like I
remember like during Pineapple Express
there was a scene where they just wanted
me to lay on the ground and I knew that
the camera wasn't on me it was so far
away so I'm like I never see that I'm
going to lay there for [ __ ] eight
hours right yeah and it's like dude
you're in a movie with James Franco and
Seth Rogen lay there right but I didn't
do that but you say like I'm not doing
it have a stand and do it yeah and then
we're like okay no it would have caused
a problem did it yeah interesting there
was a problem and um I wish I hadn't
done that he's not very good now I'll
stay there for [ __ ] 19 hours I'm not
in Kenya with no water I got you how
long you only lay I'll lay there and
talk him dead yeah and that way I show
up early you know the job be pleasant to
be I get a movie this summer independent
and they called me in at like 6 p.m.
night show 8 a.m. the next day I didn't
shoot at all yeah and they came up to me
goes we didn't get to your scene not
cool cinema but 10 years ago
[ __ ] you know would you well yeah really
only take that not [ __ ] you but I would
have called somebody okay you know mean
pie I don't I don't say anything that's
fine I get it you know and you you know
I you I have to it's softened me those
years of no work because I realize that
you can go away so quickly
yeah I don't take it for granted I yeah
I really am extremely grateful and it's
easy and it's fun and I'm lucky you just
pick now you pick your battles and
there's no bottles usual ever saying no
huh why yeah I mean your yeah because
it's like I'm already here I'm already
doing I already made a call right Italy
so yeah I'm so lucky
yeah I don't give a [ __ ] bro do you
think lately there's been more work for
minority actors yes I didn't I had a lot
to do with the - yeah because you're
like one of the better ones at it so now
it's like well we need to cast more
minorities well you had changed in that
way where I can feel it a little bit of
like yeah you know projects that
normally wouldn't even consider someone
like me or at least I'm in like I was
watching a trailer baby driver it's a
big movie with Kevin Spacey and I
remember I read for that yeah I read for
Aquaman I'm reading for things but there
are like pretty big that would never
read me and I can see them trying yeah
and you know as long as you see that and
you also look at the face of television
now um I just think that it's it's good
for us you know I think that our
presidency you know art is not good but
yes you know other than that I think
Hollywood is kind of I bet that they do
make choices or a little um yeah like
where's the the last movie that just
came out that was starting a white
person playing garlic johansson and
ghost in the shell yeah wasn't there
even one after that where someone was
playing Matt Damon in China something
volcana great wall yeah it was wooden
dr. strange yeah there's a saying there
was one a last one that they just booked
I forgot what it was but yeah but yeah I
feel like now there's way more you know
like places like Netflix and Amazon and
a kind of thing that can just be like
we're gonna play there like a niche
market now I think I also think that
it's know they now you see now is it
what it is is that my specific situation
is because of ironically how good Ike's
doing Barinholtz
and key and Peele yeah because Jordan
you know did last year he got me in that
commercial campaign okay and they are
trying to help me right so their success
okay I'm getting a lot of kind of MADtv
residual love yeah right because those
kids that saw us then you know are now
some of them are now in situations where
they can help you yeah right and I was
also Hollywood is changing yeah it's a
combination of a different couple of
things and there's also more jobs yeah I
believe this is like this perfect storm
and you're like you've been around just
long enough to be I don't know I looked
at a face book I look at people down
with the high school with I look fine
yeah yeah I do I look at America you
know why you fine for you know yeah life
is really a yeah like it's good yeah
look at me I'm fine yeah yeah you own
your own place you have a I look at the
Comedy Store I mean that's another one
that you know you and I were there at
the Comedy Store when it was half closed
it really it was me with a business yeah
it literally was on a Saturday night
twelve people
it was pretty shitty it was like a
terrible and the liners were terrible
you know and you and I Sebastian there's
a couple of us yeah that kind of went
you know what this is a club yeah and
we're gonna stay here yeah they'll book
us yeah and we we I we really reap the
Dalek benefits because we're still there
yeah and um we survived all these
regimes yeah and now it's the best club
I mean I can't believe when I Drive
there I can't believe it's where it's at
yeah boggling still every time I pull
into the drug sometimes you can't pull
into the driver because there's so many
[ __ ] people yeah yeah yeah
you think I like oh the building must be
on fire and everyone's escaping oh no no
it's just yeah it's the most popular
club in America right now like tomorrow
night I got a spot in the belly room
what do you mean son it's good as
Memorial Day weekend okay so they did a
belly room show Wow
so they're doing like a main room oh
yeah and belly I got to I got one of no
are too crazy but like the belly room is
gonna be filled yeah it's insane
it really is I mean last night even
watching guys and then being with Eddie
Pepitone Kevin Nealon a bunch of guys
these which is Eddie and Kevin were both
later we're not guys that were there
during the struggle
yeah they're just yeah creeping I mean
in Apatow yeah all these guys I believe
Rogan is a part of the struggle park you
know for a long time he was the only
reason the weekends were good but
exactly yeah Jill Rogan lit was amazed
people being bummed out if he was on the
road because he'd be in town shooting
fear factor he'd be here every weekend
and yeah Friday Center is gonna be great
and then if he was on the road for like
oh we gotta suck a [ __ ] elderly yeah
terrible yeah but yeah he was here for
all that [ __ ] yeah he was there yeah
yeah and in many ways he he's a part of
the movement of the [ __ ] not being
there anymore
all right and I'm gonna name names but a
lot of comics that ran that place to the
ground
yeah in just in terms of like doing
three or four hour SATs yeah Rogan was
the one it was a whistle blower on that
[ __ ] you know and they were all weeded
out of they're not gonna name names and
I don't really want to I'm not gonna
keep saying I kind of do like in an
evening I'm gonna do it I know and I was
one year one of their friend we're not
going to do that he yeah and I still
sometimes thank him yeah you know I go
do it does it stop saying I know but
come on yeah yeah you know he did a lot
yeah yeah he's he's incredible I mean if
we're just very lucky to be there you
know how long do you think this comedy
boom will will
we'll be a boom before a bust how bust
you ever because Rio has a bust not this
little I think it's gonna stay the way
because I was there in the 90s yeah
right when comedy was real dead when it
was really dead yeah I started comedy
after the boom the boom happened the
late 80s early 90s and then as soon as I
started it was dead
yeah clubs are closing you heard the
only Asian comic anywhere I was do this
in no one else I know I was at the time
me and Ryan well jo koy he was around
back then yeah we're from on the west
coast dude when I was six months of
doing comedy I was at The Comedy Store
in La Jolla yeah and this curly-haired
Filipino kid what yeah he had a hair and
it was clear like this curly fro he
could hey my name is jo koy I live in
Vegas I go okay cool he's like I'm doing
a show Vegas come drive to Vegas I do an
open mic sir white so I go alright I
drove to Vegas for an open mic yeah
that's hilarious at his he went to UNLV
uh-huh but you know what he did for a
job well I stayed in his apartment slept
on his couch right and I was laying
there right in the morning I woke up and
he he was wearing his Mirage outfit no I
you know what he did he shoveled packer
shed for zigfried a row oh my go
what are you going you don't have a job
I know [ __ ] literally literally right
and that's what I used to do and he had
this girlfriend of the time remember
yeah I've known him since the beginning
I didn't know he'd been around now oh
yeah in fact him and Tripoli hated each
other because they're both from Vegas
Wow yeah there were rivals in Vegas I
don't give a [ __ ] if I said that was
around it's fine they're probably fine
now they're not we're still just rival
they're not Wow
yeah but um you and Jo koy the only
Asians and
now there was um uh what's his name um
Edwin San Juan oh yeah yeah um there was
a couple right Peter Chan [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] Peter Chan oh god that's what
yeah Santa I started with that he's been
around oh yeah what he's Vietnamese
right yeah he's Asian right yeah so
there wasn't the other day I never have
all yeah
I didn't really I mean here's the single
government here's a secret and I hate to
say this but when Asian comedians are to
Fabi yeah I don't like it
yeah I've always been that way about
Middle Eastern comics that I really ham
it up yeah they want day and I was told
that a lot when I first started they
were like you gotta just do more the you
lean into the Arab thing and talk more
but I'm like no yeah why I met your I'd
be forcing that [ __ ] you can talk about
it if there's a way to do is a way to do
it in your own voice but yeah yeah I'm
not even talking about the act though
right I'm talking about more just in
general SEMA Bobby right right there
wearing Skechers yeah I mean there's
something you know Hawaiian necklaces
for no reason you know just something
weird about yeah bowl haircut yeah bull
haircut no no they don't get it it was a
couple in San Diego that were like that
yeah and I made it a point to just cause
you know strife really yeah I hate it
Wow because Alyssa when Ali Wong would
you know how I met her how she was a
journalist in San Francisco yeah and I
was I did I did a movie called kickin it
old-school with Jamie Kennedy I was
doing publicity for it and Ali was a
[ __ ] journalist then Wow and she came
up to me and she was give me an
interview for giving me a new year for
the movie and then she goes I think
about doing stand-up and as soon as I
met I saw I'm like yeah
sure yeah you could just tell she was
cute he was young hip yeah right and you
go this is what I want to see you know
yeah
and then sometimes when you see some
high along the door you know no yeah no
go pass out Korea sign yeah so you're
kind of like a racist white guy about it
I care about image okay do you think
that that's a bad look for I think that
hit rid of Johnny you know that name
Johnny you was the first Asian comedians
the comic store ever had
really yeah and this is in the early 80s
yeah Johnny ed was corium way before huh
really yeah Wow Johnny youn wore a
tuxedo on stage good he's Korean huh he
would walk up a stage and his opening
line would get a two-minute laugh what
the [ __ ] should I tell you what I was
I'll give everyone a million dollars two
minutes walk in front of a packed room
and it's opening line of this no two
minute laughs know what yeah witness
this no but I know that the guy and I
also seen tapes Jesus that was back
before yeah and that's cool then yeah
but thirty years yeah but there's no way
now
yeah in anything that resembles out like
it was just like an Asian cream and
Ramona on stage I've seen that too
recently that recently I wasn't ironic
no Wow
wearing a kimono but that he was
intentionally doing that just Johnny you
and I right or no yeah he knew that if
he said how tall in a long you know
would have weird paws yeah so he goes up
on stage he doesn't say herro right away
he just stares into the audience yeah
and he says it really long like ah right
so in consuming it laughs
yeah I'm not but that's fine that I
don't know I get to date people do it
now it just kind of drives me crazy yeah
because I think after Margaret oh it's
like that but she changed it yeah she
really like showed people like oh that
Asian stereotype is not so I met a man
when you see him you're fine with it
because he's not like wearing a [ __ ]
turban they're really in like Middle
Eastern guys that are I mean I think
it's more like it's not the look because
I think that whole era of American thing
started after it was not okay to really
be a super stereotype about it yeah but
dude this is offensive to [ __ ]
everybody you know what um but my
problem is the comedians that wear every
single thought is filtered through but
you know how as Persians do it you know
how US Mexicans do it you know like is
everything in your life filtered through
you know how this race does it but man
you know you know what sons we don't eat
fried chicken do you really know I'm in
essence yeah yeah things that you know
yeah yeah you know I know you're saying
yeah I'm go to 7-eleven at 3:00 a.m. I'm
Mexican what is that really yeah
random examples filtered through this
just so they can get a laugh on the race
it's like it's it's lazy writing a and B
it's you're playing into a stereotype
that you know people will laugh at ya
that drives me [ __ ] insane no matter
what I mean right
I mean there are I mean I do I do some
of it um I do chunks of it okay what so
I'm not gonna tell you specifically but
I just know that there are some that's
in the vein of you know you know but I
don't I'm also aware of that yeah and
I'm aware when I do it but you have to
also understand that stand up
there's two real realms you live in okay
the television realm right and the road
okay and when you do the road especially
if you don't have a name you kind of
have to do that
- have you ever done Tribble gigs now
fortunately yeah I mean you you know
even you are gig one night we're doing
holiday in in Idaho and the whole town
come they don't they're not there to see
a specific person right we just want to
see some calls we want to get drunk and
like I live you know me and Stacey an
Indian guy up there and not mentioning
him being Indiana mentioned Korea yeah
yeah yeah and that's what the reality is
yeah I think that there's a response a
on your thing why do you keep looking at
it because I want the battery to Dom
when we had time was if we're at a we're
at 23 minutes just kidding which word is
love what are we exactly one hour keep
going okay I think that there's a
responsibility that our comics should
have to be like I'm not going to play
into that [ __ ] thing like all these
drunk white guys are waiting for me to
mention curry or tacos or [ __ ] kimchi
or whatever the thing is otherwise we're
not going to laugh like break the mold
break the expectation I understand that
talk about literally and he said you
mode you're gonna just say this song
yeah now cut to a guy yeah who has no
agent no manager what happens to be
Indian right and he is in some [ __ ]
Club and he doesn't think what is the
implications of my act throughout my
whole career yeah he was like how do I
survive in my immediate or in the moment
okay yeah and you can understand why
somebody would cater to those the
audience's feelings right
you know our room is packed you you want
the guy that books it once you want to
work again for all these elements are
involved I think that I understand that
and I think that everyone does that to a
do you know what you're saying to me it
reminds me of what you did to me in
[ __ ] Arizona shut the [ __ ] up all
right
no it's not listen but you would know
what you did to me in Arizona is what
you're talking about
no yeah because I did too much of that
like I'm gonna do my own thing I was
being I was being I was extra naive
about it and I we understand
I somebody with a comic would even make
certain naive choices because they just
haven't learned you know that you just
by trial you you make errors yeah I mean
obviously there's those mistakes you
learn early on but I'm saying like those
people that are passed out they're
professionals now they know they are
actively making choices they're not like
I don't know better so I'm just going to
make fun of the fact that I'm overweight
or Mexican or yeah so I think there's a
certain amount that is like fine that's
okay because you know you walk on stage
and people are focused on the fact that
you're seven foot two or whatever they
see ya make a joke about that yeah I
just move on but Donald's that you make
it but you look at a guy like Gabriel
okay I mean he's a [ __ ] Keith
pepsi-cola
right and is that wrong no think so I
don't think it is I'm proud of him yeah
I mean I think he's really super funny
and um he does some catering yeah I
think everyone to some degree does and
then it's fine if it's like a few
minutes but when it's the cornerstone of
your act it's like you know why don't
you let people do what they do you know
I do I don't then that's that
I don't go like get and try and get
anyway there's man or [ __ ] sorry like
pointy finger people but um but you look
like Ari Shaffir is a really good
example of someone who don't make a
couple Jewish jokes here and there yeah
cuz he gets that you know sometimes
that'll just get the laugh and it sounds
ridiculous but a lot of his act has it
flies directly in the face of like
you're the stereotypical Jewish guy
comedy act yeah the evening you can see
he's filthy he doesn't believe in God at
all he is just disgusting in a lot of
ways and it's [ __ ] hilarious
and he's over you here do amazing ryse
is so wonderful to me it really is it
really is it's like he did it himself
like the industry wouldn't have it so
he's like fine I'll do it on my own
yeah it's hard well he is amazing what
he did yeah um Duncan - a lot of ways no
he's doing what he does
you know ya just went straight into that
like I'm I love that psychedelic
Trippi sort of philosophical futurist
kind of like world and I'm just going to
talk about that and then there'll be a
crowd for it yeah there are the crowd
out there for it's really smart really
funny and like people went right for it
yeah I'll finally comedian that's that's
doing this but that could take a
question about the comedy boom oh yeah
you think I'll never I'll tell you why
because you have stuff like this like
podcasts really what wasn't a thing okay
and it is an alternative to radio it is
an alternative to even listen to music
in your car
yeah and it's not becoming a form of I
feel like it's now going to be like a TV
show where it's going to be a part of
everyday culture okay
and right now in a couple of years
you'll see Entertainment Weekly do the
top 10 best podcast in the country I
mean you'll start seeing it in heart
paint like magazines and yeah and I
think that it's going to be and this is
completely tied into live shows yeah you
know like I could see from my upon cast
Tiger belly my numbers go up on their
own Dennis Lee yeah I hear people in the
crowd sometimes like yelling phrases
from from the show me why and I am
really yeah and I can't believe I didn't
do this enough to me sometimes ago hey
you were great on tiger belly and then I
go I've never done it so it's rare that
you'd say that yeah yeah Bobby the refer
you on the list do it and um okay I mean
what do you want
there's no you don't have to think I'm
what you're going to do it it's like you
know no but you listen I wanted to say
something you [ __ ] [ __ ] I just
saw every better friend we are better
from that so can I do this I helped you
move that guy's can okay I've done
[ __ ] listen I've done about 90
episodes of tiger belly all I mean
you're not even in the top 90 we've had
10 guests oh you know a lot of guy no oh
okay and when we do gasps once a month
yeah we had what last time were like big
names Eric Stonestreet before that
Jordan Peele right Bryan Callen Chris
D'Elia
you're gonna get there yeah wait a
couple years it is fun not having to
have gas I bet right it's good yeah I
might come here Monday and I we don't
have this money
and whenever you want however you feel
Monday night and um and also people ask
me which is great as she to do it yeah I
don't I can't ask people yeah I can't go
because I hate I did ask one guy at DJ
today Dillon Francis I go do you want to
do it and he didn't respond to me and it
hurts my feelings so in your head he
looked at that taksa went hey guys just
like 12 people that yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay there with Diplo and they're just
laughing on the other face yeah oh yeah
yeah so I don't like to ask but anyway
um you'll get on it soon
you know like we said we're old friends
you know you're so uncomfortable about
it uncle Olli kidding I'm sure I'll be
on it you know what now but I got it now
anyway good point you'll never gonna be
on that I'm totally fine with it
absolutely but man you're you're bad but
uh but here's what I'll do okay this
Monday mm-hmm I will mention your
podcast what's it called it's called
Nick America I'll tell people to watch
it your episode will come out on Tuesday
so it'll be perfect I will plug it
Monday night for Tuesday it'll be
perfect time yeah so you think the boom
is here in a lot of ways to stay because
of podcasting and that's sort of a
higher let's put it this way comedy
clubs at least is three in LA that's in
the tub isn't closing ever oh yeah they
will always be open yeah they've been
open doing the dark times will stay open
yeah I think the extra clubs that are
opening and those ones will do it yeah I
think so the comedy boom as it exists
now we're like every night the store and
all these clubs are sold out as like
that can't last
oh yeah I'll tell you why because if it
was the old lineups yeah right but when
you have and the other night this was
literally the lineup Rogan Sebastian
Maniscalco Kevin Neyland um me um it was
just like 10 guys yeah that were on it
Joey Diaz yeah in a row it's gonna
2:53 repeat venue yeah it's always gonna
sell out I mean a Rogen alone
yeah we'll fill whether you put
Sebastian in there and you put like Bill
burr or whoever might be it's [ __ ]
it's not it's that Club may be the boom
but that Club as long as Adam stays
there oh yeah
you think Adam will stay there I don't
but I think is gonna even move on yeah
if I mean if he's smart he'll move on to
some bigger better thing yeah yeah then
later which I think everybody but do you
think that it's better now or do you
think you're miss commies rain [ __ ] what
I miss his reign he was I mean he was
the [ __ ] worst in so many ways yeah
he was braces very racist a very
closed-minded person in terms of what
the world of comedy meant and how far
out a tree in his head it was like The
Comedy Store was the beginning middle
and end of all of it and like the people
there were the best comics in the world
he had no idea he didn't know who Brice
sure was Patton Oswalt and people like
that until he didn't have a patent
although it was until he saw him
mentioned in Entertainment Weekly that
was his source for entertainment
Nash Marilyn Rice club I Marilyn and I
go there yeah and this is like I think
her eighth season of 24 just ended right
and I woke up to Tommy because she
wanted to go to stand up a night and I
hated Marilyn she was too well on
Sundays she could sign oh yeah you'd do
that to N and I'm like no I'm sorry
she's a TV star he do that to Hannibal
Buress yeah it's crazy
he's like yeah we have an open mic and
editor done and he's like cool thanks
Malik he didn't say anything about it
yeah yeah okay that was weird and then
yeah a couple comics and they were like
okay hey dude um you know yeah on his
way up he's done blah bah bah bah bah
and then he was like oh I didn't know
it's like you you should know yeah that
you know that's what's great about Adam
he knows too much almost yeah he knows a
lot about comedy like comics like I'm
yeah yeah he's cool everyone gets along
with them also just who's there now yeah
it's insane I mean there's a point to
keep I mean there is a part of me that
goes you got to still think about
the store guys yeah uh yeah operand
comers
no it's not just that it's is that there
is loyalty right and it should always be
loyalty right and there is just a group
of guys there that put their lives ice I
literally will say that I have put blood
sweat and tears into that [ __ ] place
every two you know and I have I used to
work there I was there during the dark
ages
I know mid see what I know everyone I
mean I've done everything and so my fear
was that I would be out you know look it
was in the case but he she he I think
he's doing a great job I think that is
that we've ever had yeah yeah yeah yes
um I just think like now there's like
you know Netflix is now doing a new
comedy special every week for the rest
of the year yeah and then there's like
see so and Showtime and HP and all these
different things like those are the
things that now comics in comedy are
talking about now going like it's just
too much now like how much more of this
will people put up with and then finally
go like I I can't even keep up or pay
attention a lot of these aren't that
great
just no more that's what I was the last
boom except there weren't podcasts and
and a lot of one-hour specials it was
just a bunch of shows like okay why if
no to just to make your argument is that
she'll back then there was cable but not
a lot uh-huh I think vh1 had won MTV had
won and they were like they were on
showcase stand-up shows like evening at
the improv and 20 others line there was
no one good on those rarely okay right
I'm just gonna say this okay is that it
there's so many channels now that
they're gonna keep making them to
compete right because if somebody if
Netflix Elvis and says we're not doing
any more
Caesars gonna go we're gonna do yeah or
some other [ __ ] people oh yeah anyway
learn more
yeah so the reason why you don't see HBO
doing as much now is because there's so
much out there and they've never done a
lot in a year they've always been like
Peter very picky they treated them as
special yet another thing that drives me
crazy a bottom but it's okay
yeah because till the cream always rises
the top the top yeah one couple of guys
that we know that other specials suck
there's a lot of a lot of shitty and
we're not even shitty but just like hey
that could have been a better half hour
special or maybe you should have waited
another year you know like not like yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah but yeah I mean I
think everyone right now is just like
get while the gettin's good kind of
thing and but I feel like it's done a
lot of good for like people that were
marginalized before like a lot of like
minority actors and comedians who used
to really complain a lot like every role
goes to white guys the only minority
roles are for the stereotypes now
they're getting into more things there's
more projects that are not catered to
white audiences they'll just be shows
that specifically have to do with a
growing up Latino or like you guys show
with the idea you know this shows about
whatever takes place in the oil needs to
be a little growth and well we're just
in terms of Hollywood in general but
they're getting better and the prime
example of that is just me just getting
a show without even auditioning yeah is
a to me playing a non-story yeah yeah I
took a big sign of like okay yeah really
is yeah so are we done you want to be
done yeah okay I mean how many long do
we do we did an hour 15 that's so long
that's for me yeah that's good it's not
like I was like we have to do two hours
we just talked and so we're like you
know it feels good it didn't feel good
yeah I said I felt really good yeah I
like yeah I did also my head I'm like I
can't do any more fun that's when they
end is when you're like hey I think
we're done
maybe I should I said it out loud it
doesn't matter why you all why'd you
roll your eyes now because there's no
[ __ ] rule it's a podcast it could be
thirty minutes or two and a half hours
yeah anything in between that feels good
your wall does it take you to get ready
in the morning
what do you mean like your hair and the
way your skin is it's not like I'm one
riser on or no I just take a [ __ ]
shower and I comb my hair well yeah but
you don't just comb it dude it's you
know what's good about having short hair
that you just comb over to the side yeah
it's always sort of combed and then I
will you put dippity-do or something on
it if I do that like once every four or
five days and I just don't take a
[ __ ] shower and shampoo my hair
everyday if I did that any longer I just
comment and then who you see wearing a
shirt a jacket in getting first of all
you know I know you can't watch ladies
and gentleman but when he says short
jacket and jeans a gray t-shirt this is
like only one but you do have the bling
around your neck I wanna change yeah
yeah all right it's so with the genes
the gene stand up for a second you're
gonna I know where you're going to do no
I'm not gonna do anything just handle a
second there we go the pen crease you
love the purpose to do pancreases what
kind of jeans are those these are
Stevenson overall company yeah yeah yeah
I got a lot denim I got yeah raw denim
got myself edge how much I'd rather not
say yeah because you 200 any price
people pay that's what I pay yeah yeah
everyone dream the legislation there
were 250 maybe it was a sponsorship deal
I know that one day I couldn't even
afford one of them but um now these are
lower just wearing jeans though I'm
wearing raw denim yeah Premium rush
shoes yeah I mean is really enough is
I'm wearing you're almost wearing the
same thing I'm wearing you're wearing
raw denim I'm wearing a pair three
hundred or raw denim okay yeah mine were
less than that okay you know where I got
into gym maybe she should that's
probably worth more than the jeans
easily more than anything I want yeah
I'm not arguing again of it if you were
to send Lugo your honor yeah I dressed
already cool but if you're right right
right but I'm not you're making you're
trying to like upsell upsell but you're
trying to make what I'm wearing look I
admit saying that you let me know that
you purposely do things them look cool
okay you know what I just say this I'm
gonna do you know why can I just say
something real quick yeah all right so
this is how raw denim works you don't
know I know okay I do know right where
are you know they're like cardboard when
you first get them because they're
rather not pretty washed and let me walk
away you walk around with them and it
quickly creates these really cool
creases when they get dirty
yeah but they're natural creases but
sometimes people will put an object in
their pockets like you like a wallet or
a wallet or Copenhagen you know in a tip
crass knuckle brass knuckles or a pen
yeah that I write they can they can make
a crease so that people can go oh my god
those are brass knuckles or Chinese
start that they carry around you do a
pen and you purposely do creases with
your pen because who puts a pin in the
same exact spot every single [ __ ] time
same people who put a wallet in the same
spot every time
why is it so weird to you if you were in
cargo pants you wouldn't put the [ __ ]
wall in the same spot every time yeah I
would are you winning a new plane isn't
critic Rhys so I don't know well I don't
want a wallet [ __ ] crease I don't want
like do you want a pancreas no it's just
that's one happy pair of jeans in there
Jenna know what else I have what is is
that on the my back pocket where on my
notebook is it fade you don't think I
haven't noticed that either [ __ ] face
but that's where I always am understand
what every offensive I know that that's
the reason here's the thing is why it
drives you so crazy why because you
can't get your genes to fade as well as
you like and then you see that I have
stuff in my pockets and it fit so then
you do stuff like you rub dirt on them
and you put sandpaper and you try and
get it to work so you're just a mad that
I my jeans are fading faster because I
walk around more and that happens and
just didn't know like I can't get these
jeans of head then you look up things
online and then you like look up photos
my jeans did you go [ __ ] Pancras how
did he do it then you go buy sandpaper
on my phone paper and you know that I
bought sandpaper for my [ __ ]
converse you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you
know the I feel stuff like that I
[ __ ] drove from Phoenix to LA to see
my parents
you know I bought a brand new pair of
Converse I test
back of my [ __ ] Prius I mean so yeah
and I drove with them in the dragging
how long do I have to amazing like I'm
gonna do it from now on that's a good
idea shirts that you used to get and
like leave out in the Sun to try and get
yeah did that ever work nope really I
spent years on one of them you think it
would it doesn't and like wash it a bug
it's go-to made worn and see what
they're really doing so I'm taking me
there you haven't been there yet oh yeah
Adam we go when you took Adam no Dean
did I'll take you wanna go this week
yeah that's all right
end it now though yeah this is fine
that's over thanks for dinner